This is Jocko podcast number
eight with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
In 1952 a young marine Robert a Gannon,
arrived on shore at Incheon Korea where
he was going to be shipped north to
fight.
As they gathered to head north,
he saw stacks of c bags,
which is like a military duffle bag
and he saw him sitting in the rain.
No one had to explain what they were
doing there or why they belong to marines
that had been killed on the front.
Yeah,
he wrote this poem years later
about seeing those sand bag,
seeing those sea bags piled high
when clouds are gray and lowering
and fog obscures the plane.
I sometimes think I catch a
site of sea bags in the rain.
I know what is a vision
to a theorial to last,
but it brings a wisp of sadness
and a haunting of the past.
We'd come ashore at Inchon in
1952 and administrative landing,
just a unit passing through.
We mustered at the rail head lining up
to board a train when through the stormy
darkness.
I saw sea bags in the rain,
there was no need to question why they
were lying there looking lonely and
abandoned in the damp Korean air.
They're owners had gone northward and
would not return again from where Hell's
of bitter battle took the
lives of fighting men.
Now when fog and darkness gather,
I rarely can restrain my sad and thoughts
of Incheon and see bags in the rain.
So imagine that you're a young marine who
has joined the Marine Corps and you're
fired up and you have the visions of glory
and that romantic vision in your mind
of what war is going to be like.
And you get to Korea and it's
an administrative landing.
So there's no shooting going on and
you're now you're on the ground and you're
in Korea and then you muster to go
north and go to the battlefield,
go to the front and you see these see
bags of all these marines that had been
killed in combat.
And you
imagine what that does psychologically
to guys and obviously to a Robert
[inaudible], Gannon, it affects
him, affected him his whole life.
And he still thinks about it.
And as much of a
intense experience as that is
the Marine Corps has been
walking past those bags,
you know,
theoretically walking past those bags
for over 200 years and going forward,
going into the fray towards the risk
towards in many cases toward death.
And I'm kind of leading in with talking
about the Marine Corps tonight who I
have just absolute respect for
the United States Marine Corps.
We worked closely with them when we
were in Ramadi in 2006 mostly with the,
the three eight marines, which is the
third battalion, Eighth Marine regiment.
And they were there for the
bulk of the deployment with us.
Then they got relieved by the one six
marines who arrived towards the end of our
crews. And, but prior to that,
my whole career I was
working with marines.
I was did multiple shipboard
deployments with marines.
I did a turnover with the first MARSOC
company in Baghdad and 2004 so I know
marines well. And like I said,
they just have my absolute respect.
And
as a warrior class,
which is what they are,
a warrior class of men and women,
their professionalism
and their commitment,
it is,
it's impeccable.
And because they fought,
you know,
in all major wars,
they know and understand combat very
well and therefore they know and they
understand combat leadership very well.
And with that we are going to look tonight
at what used to be called the f m one
tax zero and that was the
fleet marine force manual,
which is now called the MC WP,
the Marine Corps war fighting publications
six [inaudible] 11 and the title of
the of the document is
called leading marines.
And so what I did as a kind of like I
do with most of these books that we look
at,
I went through it and found the pieces
that struck me as highly applicable to
combat,
which makes them highly applicable to
life and to business and to the way we go
through this world.
Right.
So I've pulled some of these ideas out,
some quotes out,
some sections out to talk about
and discuss.
And here we go.
Imagine you are rifleman in a company
ready to assault align of enemy machine
gun bunkers.
You are lying flat on the ground,
protected further moment by a slight
rise between you and the enemy,
but just above your head,
the anemia,
the enemy's guns are throwing a visible
and audible curtain of lead which thuds
into the trees around you, causing you
to wonder if it makes the same sound.
When it hits flesh,
you tell yourself it's impossible,
impossible to penetrate
that curtain of fire alive.
Yet in a moment a
sergeant's voice will boom,
let's go.
You can't live forever,
but I'll you hear now is
the clatter of machine guns,
the vision of dead and wounded.
You saw on the way up to the
front rises to plague you.
Your belly deflates and lies flat
against your backbone and all the gallon
thoughts you would hope
to have at this moment
are gone.
You are naked and alone with the
instinct of self preservation
and that's what soldiers and marines face.
Not all of them,
but many of them and they in these
situations and situations even worse than
this,
they do decide to go forward.
They decide to go forward into
that Maelstrom of fire and of deaf
and
soldiers in warriors have done that for
thousands of years and you ask yourself,
and the purpose that they wrote that
paragraph was so that they could ask that
question why? And here's what
the Marine Corps says about it.
Why do individuals rush forward against
their mate? Most basic instincts,
why do marines take their lives in their
hands and lead a charge straight into
enemy guns in World War II?
What was it that made marines
clamber out of their landing,
landing craft into water of unknown depth
and charge into a hail of machine gun
and artillery fire not knowing whether
they would ever make it to the beach in
Vietnam?
What was it that made a marine take
the point and start down the dark and
misdeed jungle trail at the heart of
why Marines are able to put mission
accomplishment over concerned for their
own safety is leadership leadership.
That is the combination of the intangible
elements of our ethos and the more
tangible elements of our
leadership philosophy.
So they're saying that this courage comes
from the leadership and from the ethos
that they live.
That is,
that is brought to the troopers
through the leadership,
which is a pretty profound statement.
It's a very profound statement and I
jumped out of this manual for a moment and
I grabbed sort of the marine corps
principles of leadership there. Key words.
Here they are, justice,
judgement, dependability,
initiative, decisiveness, tact, integrity,
enthusiasm, bearing on selfish, nish,
courage, knowledge, loyalty,
endurance.
Those are the traits that they talk
about and what I actually from that list,
I think they're all pretty pretty
obvious why they're on that list.
The one exception or I would say the one
that stands out to me a little bit as
maybe what people wouldn't
expect his tact. Yeah.
I didn't say tactical or tactics.
I said tact and they actually go on
to define that a little bit further.
The definition of tact is the ability to
deal with others in a manner that will
maintain good relations and avoid offense.
More simply stated,
tact is the ability to say and do
the right thing at the right time.
So obviously almost every time we sit
down at this podcast table and do our work
here,
we end up somehow talking about the
interactions between human beings and they
actually put this as a, one of their
tenants is that you have to have tact.
The, the quality of
consistently treating peers,
seniors and subordinates with respect
and courtesy is a sign of maturity.
Tact allows commands,
guidance and opinions to be expressed
in a constructive and beneficial manner.
This deference must be
extended under all conditions,
regardless of true feelings,
regardless of true feelings.
They are saying you,
despite the fact that that person annoys
you or that you'd think you could do a
better or all those things that
we talk about regularly here,
you have to have tact regardless
of your true feelings. Yeah.
Like, you know how you know
people, rude people, for example,
they'll, they'll, they'll
say stuff like, hey,
it was true. You know, they'll say
something that's rude or whatever,
and there'll be like, hey, I speak
the truth. If you don't like it.
Kinda that's like lack of tact. That is,
I've always, I've always thought that.
Were you always wondering why those people
aren't in leadership positions?
Yeah, for the most part,
they don't have tact because who wants to
be around somebody that acts like this?
And what's interesting about it is,
you know,
one of the other words that they
have honors integrity, right?
And yet they're saying that, you know,
regardless of your true feelings,
so there's a little bit of a deck
of a dichotomy there, you know,
and to be the person that says, well, it's
true, so I'm just going to say it right.
No tact should override integrity in
dealing with people and human emotions.
Yeah.
And it,
that's kind of what I've always thought
when I hear people say rude things and
be like, oh, it's okay for me to say
these kinds of the kinds of things.
Because they're true, even though a
lot of times it's just their opinion,
but they kind of,
it's cloaked in this like presentation
that they're just being honest,
you know? So, yeah. That's
interesting how it's, Oh,
they're saying the tact overrides
that quote unquote honesty. Yeah. Um,
you know, for the, for the sake of
leadership or the group or whatever. Yeah,
no doubt about it. Um, so
now as we get into this,
in what leaders,
what leaders are actually leading against.
Now of course there's an
enemy. You're right. There's
a force that's opposing you.
So you're leading against them,
but they have another word that,
and the word is friction.
And this is something for anybody that
knows anything about sort of military
science, understand, understands and
has heard the word friction before.
And it's a word that comes from Carl
von Clausewitz who was a great Prussian
Dren general born in 1780 fought in the
Ryan campaigns and the Napoleonic wars
was a famous military theorist
and he wrote the famous book,
Vaughn Craig,
which means on war.
So that was his, that was his
sort of masterpiece that he wrote.
And it's well read by anybody
that's in the military. It has red
on war by crosswords.
So friction is a term that
he coined as far as I know,
it's a term that he coined.
I haven't read it prior to him.
And to talk about friction here
as what Clausewitz says about it.
And this is from onshore.
Then again,
I departed from the Marine Corps manual
here for a few minutes to go a little
bit deeper into friction.
Everything is very simple in war,
but the simplest thing is difficult.
Hmm.
These difficulties accumulate and produce
a friction, which no man can imagine.
Exactly who has not seen war.
So when war through an influence of an
in an infinite of petty circumstances,
which cannot properly be described
on paper, things disappoint us.
And we shot and we fall short of the rank.
So this idea of friction is all the little
things that build up against you and
against what you're trying to accomplish.
And I love what he says next.
A powerful iron will
overcomes this friction.
It crushes the obstacles.
So your will can overcome them.
But there's a,
but there's a caveat,
but certainly the machine along with them
so your iron will can
smash these obstacles,
but it does take a toll on the will.
The strong will of a proud spirit stands
prominent and commanding in the middle
of the art of war. And we'll get
to, we'll a little bit later,
but right now we're
talking about friction.
Activity in war is movement
in a resistant medium.
So it's, it's, you know,
as opposed to doing stuff on the ground
and the air you didn't get in the water
or you're doing it in all your,
all you're doing in something that
is slowing you down and stops you.
It is there for this friction
or what is so termed here,
which makes that which appears
easy in war, difficult in reality.
And I will tell you,
in working with all kinds
of companies and businesses,
there's friction in every business.
There's friction, everything,
every goal that people
have in a business world,
there's friction and resistance to
trying to stop me from getting there and
obviously that just slides right over
into your life and those goals that you
have and you're fighting against this
friction and what is this friction?
This friction is everything.
It's everything that is stopping you
from achieving your goal and in war,
it's what the enemy does. It's the whether
it's a lack of ammunition, it's the,
it's the materials that you need that
are arriving in time. It's a muddy road.
It's a strong, a strong wind.
It's all these little things.
It's the weird attitude of
your subordinates. It's the,
it's the mental capacity of your
leadership. It's all these things.
Create this friction that are going
to stop you from achieving your goals,
or at least it's going to try to
stop you from achieving your goals.
And it's the same thing when you get a
business that's trying to make something
happen. You know, when you
go to formulate a business,
this is not an easy process.
This is a challenging process and there's
a friction that comes up against you.
And obviously, like I said,
with your personal goals,
we see friction all the time. Now
the Marine Corps, here's their take.
So that was some class fits and it was
a little bit of an abridged version,
but you know, um, uh, bridging.
So this one is the marine corps and
you'll notice a little bit more clarity
because it's written directly
in English by Marines. So it's,
it's clearer. And here's the
Marine Corps take on friction.
Friction dominates war.
It makes simple tasks,
hard acts constantly to tear down
the will of the individual marine and
interferes with unit cohesion.
It operates across the entire spectrum
of conflict from garrison activities to
combat from senior command elements down
to the most forward fighting position.
So the friction is everywhere. It's
everywhere. It's on the front line.
Troopers are feeling
friction. You know, the,
the senior command has friction that in
this day and age that friction can be
loss of connectivity. You know, you're
sitting there on the, on the Internet,
when you trying to communicate with
troops that are in the field nowadays that
Internet goes down, there's friction or
your broadband cable gets stuffed up.
It's literally, that's friction.
Everything is friction.
Friction can be caused by external
factors such as physical environment,
the nature of the mission
or friendly or enemy action.
Inadequate or inaccurate intelligence
also contributes to friction by causing
uncertainty.
This uncertainty is sometimes called the
fog of war where things are not always
what the leader expected.
This expression,
this expression describes both
the literal fog created by dust,
smoke and debris on the battlefield.
And more importantly,
the mental fog of confusion
and uncertainty created by
lack of knowledge of the
enemy,
chaotic noise,
mental and physical fatigue and fear.
And interestingly, uh, Lafe and I,
the book that we wrote, extreme
ownership, the first chapter,
it's called the fog of war.
And it is,
and I talk about this fact right here.
It was the literal fog of war because
it was burning tires in the streets,
creating suit everywhere.
And there was concrete dust
floating through the air
and smoke from machine guns
and and smoke from smoke grenades.
And so there's a literal fog
of war where you can't see.
And then on top of that you add the
theoretical fog where I didn't know where
everyone was and I wasn't
sure what was happening.
And so this fog of war is so very real
frictions.
Most lethal form,
it's most lethal form,
however
is self induced and maybe
termed internal friction.
So this again,
it's just incredible how
these theories of war,
parallel life and although you have these
things that are going on in your world
that are trying to stop you from
achieving your goals, [inaudible]
the most lethal force of friction is self
induced. It's what you do to yourself.
Fear of the unknown breeds this paralysis.
It is best overcome by
vigorous leadership,
which clearly sets out what is happening,
how would is happening and most
importantly why is why it is happening.
So again,
it is
almost,
I don't know if at some point I'm going
to stop being surprised and stop being
shocked and stop being
stop being amazed in that
and the parallels between
a war and life and this is
just one of them. Another one of them
to the the self induced friction.
Yes. I think a big one that
I've kind of noticed in,
I think most people have, this
is his pet peeves. You know,
people will have these pet
peeves about like for example,
when people call me boss, you know, you
don't, you know, when people say, Hey,
what's up? You talked about
on the first podcast. Yeah.
So when they some friction
with Echo Charles. Yeah.
And this totally self induced don't
mean anything bad by the word boss.
But meanwhile I'm like, I have this
little almost like check against them,
you know, because they referred
to me as boss or, dude,
I don't know why I do not actually,
you know what if a girl calls me dude,
it's like it's, it seems real
condescending even though
I, I figured they don't,
but that could jam up the relationship
and potentially jam up any kind of task
we have.
That can be just,
just one little element at a jam
you up and pet peeves in general.
I know it'll get in people's way. Yeah.
Pet peeves are stupid in my opinion.
So you need to correct yourself on that
one. Yeah. But there are, I mean it's,
we could, we could just sit here and
the rest of this podcast, could you be,
you and I coming up with the various
frictions in life, whether it's, you know,
wanting to sleep more, wanting to not, not
the gym isn't close enough to my house.
The, you know, it's, you've
got a million reasons. Yeah.
You got a million pieces of
friction. Countless. Or as they say,
as the Marine Corps says,
countless minor incidents,
the kind you can never really first see
combine to lower the general level of
performance. So that one always
fall short of the intended goal.
And this is very similar to
class fits here. I yearn,
willpower can overcome this friction
it pave arises every obstacle,
but of course it wears
down the machine as well.
You can see they obviously took
that directly from Clausewitz. Okay?
Whatever form it takes,
because war is a human enterprise.
Friction will always have a psychological
as well as a physical impact.
So you're getting worn,
you are getting worn down by the friction.
Friction is inevitable.
Marine leaders must accept it,
do everything in their power to
minimize its effects and learn to fight
effectively in spite of it.
What I,
one of the things that I really like
about this term is that it captures
everything and it turns everything.
You know,
it clarifies what you're up against.
You're not just up against all these
little things. You're applicants friction.
And actually, uh, I was with, uh,
Joe Rogan and he talked about this book,
the war of art,
which I haven't read yet by Pressfield.
And he does the same thing, but what
does he call it? He calls it resistance.
And so it's the same idea. You
know, you put a name on your enemy,
you identify them,
whether it's laziness or sugar or lack
of movement or whatever that thing is.
That's what they do.
And,
and it allows you to identify it
and be aware of what is happening.
Now,
speaking of how to overcome that,
this next part of leadership here is it,
and we already mentioned it's will,
and it's something that I obviously
identify as extremely important
because it's the driver
of life.
It's the driver of your discipline
is your will to make things happen.
And it keeps us on the path. You know,
it keeps us on the path to victory.
And I talked about it when I was on the
Sam Harris' podcast and I also talked
about it on the history channel when
they formed the live to tell episode,
which is about Mark Lee, the first seal
killed in Iraq. And I talked about,
you know,
what does it take to win?
And the most important thing it
takes to win is will the will to win.
So the Marine Corps goes into a story
that's about will and I'm going to read
it,
assigned to defend a three mile mountain
pass along the division's main supply
line and commanding the
only route of approach.
Captain Barbara took position with his
battle weary troops and before nightfall
had dug in and set up a defense along
the frozen snow covered hillside.
Okay.
When a force of estimated
regimental strength savagely
attacked during the night
and flipping has heavy casualties and
finally surrounding his position following
a bitterly fought seven hour conflict.
Captain Barber after repulsing,
the enemy gave us [inaudible] that he
could hold if supplied by airdrops and
requested permission to stand fast after
orders were received to fight his way
back to where we're leaving force.
After two reinforcing units had been
driven back under fierce resistance in
attempts to reach the isolated troops.
So here was Captain Barber with his
troops there on this ridge line.
They hold off the enemy and then
they get told, hey, you know what?
Now that you've held the enemy off,
go ahead and fight back to our position.
And he says, no, no, we're not fighting
back. We're going to stay here.
We're going to hold this ground.
Although severely wounded,
Captain Barbara continued to
maintain personal control,
often moving up and down the lines
on a stretcher to direct defense and
consistently encourage and inspiring
his men to supreme efforts.
Despite the staggering opposition waging
desperate battle throughout five days
and six nights of repeated onslaughts
launched by fanatical aggressors,
he and his heroic command accounted for
approximately 1000 enemy dead in this
epic stand in bitter subzero weather.
And when the company was relieved,
only 82 of his original 220 men were
able to walk away from the position.
So valiantly defended
against in Superbowl odds,
his profound faith and courage,
great personal valor and
unwavering fortitude,
which is, in other words, his will.
We're decisive factors in the successful
withdraw of the division from the death
trap in the chosen reservoir sector.
That's a will. And that shows
you what will is capable of.
I mean, when you talk about
subzero temperatures, you put,
you just put people out in sub zero
temperatures for a night that we'll break.
Most people now get attacked all night
now stay up there for five
days and six nights. It's just,
it's the only thing that can win
in that battle is will human will
from the same battle.
Lieutenant Colonel Murray,
who was commanding the
fifth marines at the chosen,
where's a var summed up what was
required of leaders. And this is, um,
very impactful.
When I read this,
I personally felt in a state of shock,
the kind of shock one gets from
some great personal tragedy.
The sudden loss of someone close.
So he gets into this bad situation.
That's what feels this guy's the commander
of all those marines in the chosen
what reservoir.
And he gets this shock like someone
like someone's died and he feels it.
And then he says,
my first fight was within myself.
I had to rebuild that emptiness of spirit.
And you know, I get asked,
I've gotten asked on Twitter,
I've gotten some direct messages,
people that ask me about loss,
they've lost people
that are close to them,
whether it's guys talking about being in
combat or whether it's people that are
in civilian world and disease or
accidents has taken people from them.
And I think one of the
things that the kind of the,
the thing that I say to people
when they say, look, this is,
this is crushing me and I feel horrible
and I don't know if I'm going to be able
to get back and, and, and my
first statement is always like,
of course,
of course.
And that is normal.
It is normal for you to feel
that way when you lose people.
And you could see that this,
you know,
lieutenant colonel in combat,
he went through the same thing.
This hardcore Badass marine had to go,
okay,
I fuel this loss and I have to rebuild.
I have to rebuild.
The fight was within himself.
And so I think that's very important
for people that are listening,
this podcast that are in the military.
You are going on the battlefield and you,
if you're in the,
if you're fighting long enough,
you will have casualties.
And that is one of the things I
know when my guys were killed,
I felt the same damn thing,
the horrible,
wretched emptiness.
And
I knew I had to rebuild it.
And,
and so reading this quote
definitely brings me back to that.
And it clarifies it when I talked to other
people about losing someone that that
last,
that you're feeling that emptiness,
that shock is normal and it's okay and
don't think that it's going to just
disappear.
You've got to rebuild it.
You got to rebuild that spirit.
And so this manual goes on to say for
leaders to hold units together under
adverse conditions,
they first must fight and win
the battle within themselves
and that's not me talking.
That is this manual talking.
That is the Marine Corps
talking about leading marines.
They know that there's a
battle going on within you,
that there's a battle you
got to fight every day,
that there's a spirit that's got to
be rebuilt when it's broken down.
This is what combat is. This is what
war is and this is what life is.
It goes on to talk about the
difference between peace,
time and combat.
Leading in combat is vastly
different from leading in peacetime.
Anybody can give orders and have them
obeyed at a peacetime poster station
there nothing blocks the way to obedience.
The Brig,
meaning jail pay reductions in demotion
may be all the incentive necessary to
instill good order and discipline,
but
execution of orders in combat may
mean an immediate danger or even the
likelihood of getting killed.
The Marines,
the marine needs to know why an order
is given and how it is to be executed.
We talk about this all the time,
people got to know why they're
doing what they're doing.
And I'll tell you the first section of
that, the marines don't lead like that.
The Marines don't go around saying,
Hey,
you will do this or I'll send you to the
brig or I'll give you pay reductions or
demotions. That's that. That's
not how leadership works.
And it's not that way in the Marine Corps.
Of course,
those are there if you need them.
But you don't want to lead like that.
You don't want to lead with beatings.
Yeah.
Above all,
marines need to feel that the leader
giving the order knows what he or she is
about.
Even given the best trainings,
how marines perform will depend
on the kind of leadership they had
by the example. And courage demonstrated
by their leader. Napoleon said,
there are no bad regimens,
only bad kernels,
which is very interesting.
And it's a very common statement
that Napoleon said. And uh, you know,
we've talked where we've done the,
the about face on this,
cause David Hackworth says there's
no bad units, only bad officers,
and then lay off. And I and extreme
ownership. We have, there's no bad teams,
only bad leaders and they always
say there's no bad students.
There's only bad teachers.
So there's no bad students who
was only in bed instructors.
That's like the thing,
right is the same thing.
It's the same thing and you know from
Napoleon to Hackworth to Lafe and I saying
that, uh, what the Marine
Corps is saying here,
a unit led by an able
and aggressive leader,
aggressive leader who commands respect
because he sets the example and
demonstrated courage and confidence
will perform any task asked of them.
Okay?
Not some tasks, not most of
the tasks, not the easy tasks.
Any task.
Okay.
Aggressive leader who commands respect
because set the example and demonstrated
courage and confidence will
perform any tasks asked of them.
That's what leadership is about.
Okay?
Now we get into the moral challenge.
Armies of superior numbers have been put
to flight before one man out of 10 is
fallen.
They were not beaten by blows,
which became more than flesh could bear.
They were beaten in
spirit according to laws,
as old as the human heart,
and the victor is the one who can best
apply those laws so you can have a great,
huge force,
a much bigger force,
and they can break before anyone's even
been killed or one of only a few people
have been killed because
their spirit is broken.
When people conduct lives built on high
moral standards and physical fitness,
they tend to develop qualities
that produce inspired
leadership and discipline.
It is not a new notion. It can be found
in any great military force in the past.
Gaining moral ascendancy requires that
subordinates feel that their leaders
genuinely care for them,
that they are fighting for a worthy cause
and ensuring that their sacrifices are
not made in vain.
I talk about that one regularly.
You're your people have got to know that.
You cannot think that you care about them.
They got to know that you care about him.
That's what leadership is.
You're leading this group because
you care about this group.
Acting as a buffer to protect subordinates
is a key responsibility of any
leader.
Leaders must avoid passing the buck.
Leaders must, if necessary, act from
the courage of their own convictions.
Even when such a position runs
counter to the policy of seniors.
We talked about that last time.
Remember Napoleon said that if,
if you're following my orders and
you get a bunch of guys killed,
it's your fault, your car, you're
culpable if it was a bad plan, right?
If you listen, if you will bade
my bad order, it's your fault.
It's the same thing
that's being said here.
Even when a position runs
counter to the policy of seniors,
leaders must always accept full
responsibility for their actions.
Hello, extreme extreme ownership, right?
They're leaders must always accept full
responsibility for actions for their
actions and like you said, extreme
ownership. That's what our books about.
Trying to make that
at the utmost level of responsibility
is to own everything that's happening
regardless of who's at fault,
who might be at fault,
what other factors were in play, doesn't
matter. Take ownership of it all.
Now we get into physical challenge.
Okay?
Physical demands of battle
encompass more than being fit.
And these demands influence
both the leader and the lead,
the effects of sleep deprivation,
poor diet, poor hygiene.
And most importantly fear have to be
understood and be a part of everyday
training.
No one is immune to fatigue.
As marines become increasingly tired,
they may lose the ability to make rapid
decisions and are susceptible to being
confused,
disoriented and ultimately ineffective.
Guts and pride are not a
substitute for fitness.
And one,
one place where that becomes completely
evident is in mixed martial arts where
you get guys, they got a lot of
guts and they got a lot of pride,
but a,
you think all this person's never going
to tap in once they get broken down and
fatigue sets in, you know, uh,
fatigue makes cowards of us all right.
It's not a substitute. So guts and
pride are not a substitute for fitness.
There are good augment to fitness, but
they don't take the place of it. Yeah.
A leader relying on guts and pride will
not be able to fully concentrate on the
mission or the task at hand.
Exact limits of endurance
cannot be determined,
but physical conditioning is one method
of reducing the effects of physical
exertion.
And it can increase individual
self confidence and reduce stress.
So I always tell people to work out,
that's why you got to get up and go.
Because it increases individual
self confidence. It reduces stress.
I'm produces the effect of
fizzle desertion it's just good.
So many benefits.
Yeah.
And that's the,
I think the most important is that
it reduces the via effects later.
So you know, if you're in
shape, your heart strong year,
your mind is strong because you've
worked out your whole life or,
or just you're just into fitness. You,
you perform. There was this, Oh man,
I heard this thing where it was an article
or I read where it said why exercise
is the most important part of business.
And um,
and the whole thing was,
you know, it said a lot,
but the whole thing was exercises.
The only thing that affects every other
part of your life, the only thing.
So you can have all these
other traits and you know,
and sure they might affect one thing.
Most things don't affect anything.
They just affect that one thing.
Like if you have money,
you go okay of money and
that affects like Xyz,
but exercise will affect
your ability to make money.
It will affect your relationship,
it will affect,
it will affect everything and it's the
one thing that does break out your jump
rope. People get out. She kettlebells
time to get it on. Yeah. That's why.
That's why if you're ever,
if you ever get in a relationship
where the girl's like,
oh,
you know you put the gym or
Jujitsu or something before me,
that's a red flag. Red Flag, red flag.
I'm not saying break up with them saying
that's a red flag. It is a warning. Yes,
it is a warning. It's some friction
at some friction. Friction.
The physical development back to the book
of the physical development of marine
leaders must include
dealing with the nature,
natural fear of interpersonal violence,
which contributes significantly
to the fog and friction of combat
dealing with the fear of
interpersonal violence.
So I talked about this with Sam Harris
and that is if you're one of the worst
things that happens when somebody
gets assaulted, if they've never been,
had somebody on them grinding on them
before in grabbing them and holding them
and smashing them,
they've never had that feeling before.
They're already way behind.
They're way behind because
they're just not used to it.
It's completely new to them.
Whereas obviously someone that trains in
martial arts like Jujitsu where you're
getting ground on and people are
smashing you and you're used to it,
it's part of your deal.
It's part of your life
and you,
and you've been in actual firefights.
But that's why getting,
getting some sort of a gun tranq gun
training or firearms training is good
because if you've never shot
a gun before and you fire it,
you don't watch the movies and stuff does
not prepare you for how loud that is.
And then like just the, just the impact
on your whole, your whole thing. You know,
when, when you fired guns. So if that were
to happen in some stressful situations,
someone attacks you or someone fires a
gun in your presence and it's, you know,
this commotion,
just dealing with the fact that a gun
was fired alone is like this huge battle
that you have to, they, you
essentially lost. Cause you're not,
you're just not used to
it. That's a hit. You know,
you need to inoculate yourself
to these situations. Yeah.
And we will actually be talking about
that a little later tonight, Tim and
units and their leaders that do not
have the mental and physical strength to
overcome fear will not be able to fight
effectively and overcome friction.
In fact, one of the greatest sources
of friction is physical exertion.
And it may be required of individuals,
units or both. And again,
the physical exertion thing,
you know,
we do at the gym,
we do Shark Tank,
right?
So guys got a fight coming up or a
guy's got a tournament coming up.
And so we put them in the middle and
they're getting fresh guys, you know,
every two minutes, one
minute, sometimes for minutes,
sometimes five minutes depending
on what they're going into.
But you can watch and see a total
destroyer of a guy after they reach that
breaking point, just get
mopped up. And again,
we're taking them there for a reason.
You know, we're taking them there.
So they do have to rely on their technique
and so they do get conditioned and
inoculated against that breaking point.
So they learn how to dig even deeper.
Yeah.
But you can get anyone there.
I mean you can get any so
physically exhausted that
they're no longer capable of
doing.
Even a slight percentage of what they
would normally be capable of [inaudible]
so you have to maintain that conditioning
at the highest level all the time that
you can.
And that's like the,
I mean really like you're saying it's,
it's not just the physical
and physical conditioning,
your conditioning them to the situation.
Like how you said when they're beyond
their physical kind of breaking point
where they don't have
all their strength date,
the point where you feel like
stopping going beyond that point,
if you rarely or never been beyond
that point, once you get there, you're,
you're completely done. Yeah. You once you
realize that you can push through that.
Yeah. That there was a little more
than you think there is. Yeah.
Conditioned to it and you're ready for it.
Yeah.
The gain in moral force deriving from
all forms of physical training is an
unconscious gain. Yeah. I actually think
it's not just an unconscious thing.
I think it's a conscious game too. I think
when I get, when I train, I feel better.
I feel stronger.
I feel sharper.
Willpower,
determination,
mental poise and muscle control arm
all march hand in hand with the general
health and wellbeing of the individual.
So again,
according to the Marine Corps that
this physical training increases your
willpower, your determination, your
mental poise, your muscle control.
Clearly,
as you stated earlier,
physical training is
important across the board.
Establishing and maintaining standards.
Maintaining this attitude and standard
of excellence is a responsibility not
limited to officer's staff,
noncommissioned officers or
noncommissioned officers.
It is the responsibility of all marines.
That's the attitude you want to have
with your team, with your company,
with your business.
That that attitude of excellence and
maintaining the standard of excellence
isn't responsibility. Just the leadership.
It's the responsibility of everyone.
Leadership in the long run depends
upon the example set by the leader,
not only as a war fighter,
but also as a citizen and a human being.
So the leader has to display a high level
of [inaudible].
I'm not sure what the right word is,
a high level of bearing,
a high level of presence in all
situations, not just as a marine,
but in all levels.
Setting a personal example requires
high moral standards, reflecting virtue,
honor,
patriotism,
and subordination and personal
behavior and in performance,
these inner qualities that mark leaders,
these are the inner qualities that mark
leaders rather than outward marks of
greatness.
They are often deeply
buried and in many cases,
one must look closely to see an
individual's inner strengths. So you're,
you're not always going to see is
not always the guy beating his chest.
That's the, the best leader.
And has an example of that here.
Major General John a lazoon
describe medal of honor recipients.
Sergeant Major John h quick perhaps
of all the marines I ever knew,
quick approached, more nearly the
perfect type of noncommissioned officer.
I'll calm, forceful, intelligent, loyal,
and courageous man. He was, I
never knew him to raise his voice,
loses temper,
used profane language and yet he
exacted and obtained prompt and explicit
obedience from all persons
subject to his orders,
the image of the marine barking orders.
You have to balance that.
You have to balance that
with the reality of the,
the example just given made
sergeant major John h quick.
In the Marine Corps,
we are trained to endure combat violence
and death along with other less arduous
situations in both peace and war.
Simply because we bear arms
and wheeled awesome power.
We do not have limitless authority
to unleash it without do requirement.
We may not say as one
enemy commander said,
kill all, burn all, destroy all.
So again,
the image and the stereotype of a marine
or of a American soldier has to be
balanced with the facts
of who they really are.
And that is that they are trained,
that they don't have limitless of 40
to unleash the awesome power without do
requirement.
Now,
of course we,
these are human beings and
there are military people
in the Marine Corps and the
army in the seal teams in special
operations that go over the line.
And that's something that gets dealt with.
So I'm not sitting here
claiming that this is a,
you know,
a perfect situation,
but I am giving you the ideal that the
Marine Corps itself sets out upon it's
marines of what it wants
their marines to be like. Hmm.
And a good, we, we, uh, actually used
to say this in the seal teams as well.
And this is how do you figure out
when something is like, you know,
the right thing to do,
do the right thing.
Because sometimes doing the right thing
is opposed to what you're being ordered
to do or what the rules are.
If you are prepared to talk about your
actions or lack thereof in front of a
national audience made up
of all your seniors, peers,
subordinates and friends who share
the same professional values and whose
opinions you value,
then your behavior was or is
probably ethical in nature.
So when you're doing something, if you
say, okay, I'm going to go on you know,
Cable News tomorrow and I'm
going to debrief everybody
what I did and if you can
be proud of it,
then it was ethical and if you're going
to be hanging your head low then it
wasn't a good decision.
You weren't doing the right thing.
And that is definitely something that I
use to guide my judgment and cause the,
again,
the,
the rules are not always what they
should be and what are the rules.
They don't fit over the
situation that you're in.
Laura is a dynamic thing and so sometimes
the rules that have been put in place
for one region, they don't
work in the region urine.
And so you have to say, okay,
do you know what by the book they could,
they could burn me on this one,
but I can look whoever's
charging me and say,
this is what I did and this is why I did
it. And if you want to send me to the,
to Leavenworth for that,
get out the handcuffs and let's go.
Hmm.
Well, this is a powerful,
this is a powerful uh,
paragraph I'm about to read and
it's actually, if you listened to
the podcast that I did with Sam Harris,
this is just a,
this is a little bit of a different
spin on bravery and on courage.
Okay.
Courage can be misunderstood.
It is more than the ability to
overcome the jitters to quell fear,
to conquer the desire to run.
It is the ability to know what
is or is not to be feared.
And infantry chart an infantry
men charging a bunker is
not hampered by the fear
that he might be struck down a
few paces from his fighting hole.
A pilot is not afraid of losing
all hydraulic power in his haircut,
in his aircraft.
They are both prepared for those outcomes.
A marine in battle fears
disgracing himself by running.
He fears not losing his life,
but losing his honor.
He may not be able to preserve his life,
but he can always preserve his honor
that much is within his power to fear
disgrace, but not deaf to fear, not duty,
but dereliction from duty.
This is courage.
The truly courageous do not live
in anxiety from morning to night.
They are calm because
they know who they are.
In that last two sentences
about the truly courageous,
do not live in anxiety
from morning to night.
They are calm because
they know who they are
in. I definitely, when
I hear that statement,
I think about the guys that I
know that we're truly courageous
and
how they did have that
almost peaceful attitude of acceptance
because they knew who they were and they
knew what they would do if the moment came
for them.
Another type of more kind of overt
courage here from Major Jim Crow,
former enlisted man, marine
gunner, distinguished rifleman.
Star football player
was a tower of strength.
Throughout the battle is trademark.
Red Mustache bristling a combat
shotgun cradled in his arms.
He exuded confidence and professionalism.
Quality sorely needed on that long day,
CHRO ordered the Coxson
of his landing craft,
put this goddamn boat in the boat,
hit the reef at high speeds,
sending the marine sprawling
quickly recovering.
Cro ordered his men over the sides,
then led them through several hundred
yards of shallow water reaching the shore
intact.
Only four minutes behind the last wave,
CHRO clenching a cigar in his teeth
and standing upright. Groundling.
It is men.
Look,
the sons of bitches can't hit me. Why do
you think they can hit you? Get moving.
Go Red Beach through you
was in capable hands,
kind of a larger than life,
a larger than life image
of courage.
Adaptability,
adaptability has long been our key to
overcoming the effects of friction and its
components. Although it is
synonymous with flexibility,
adaptability also embraces
the spirit of innovation.
Marines constantly seek
to adapt new tactics,
organization and procedures to
the realities of the environment.
Deficiencies and existing practices
are identified, outdated structure,
discarded and modifications made
to maintain function and utility.
That's a little something you
might want to do in your life.
Deficiencies in existing practices
are identified, outdated structure,
discarded and modifications made
to maintain function and utility.
Yes,
go ahead and note to self.
The ability to adapt enables marines
to be comfortable within an environment
dominated by friction
and we just talked about innovation.
Innovation has always been a key component
of marine corps tradition and our
style of leadership.
It isn't.
It has come naturally because our
combatant function was and is unique.
Innovation requires that leaders
listen to their subordinates.
I'm going to say that again.
Innovation requires that leaders listen
to their subordinates and that a two way
system of communication has
maintained. Corporals, sergeants,
captains and generals all
have responsibility to be
innovators as everybody in
your chain of command has a
responsibility to be innovational
because innovation is imprecise
and because subordinates,
especially junior one's a, we'll
make mistakes, protect them.
Zero defects are not a
standard of measurement.
They do not encourage initiative.
They stifle it.
So your junior folks and some of your
junior leadership and maybe some of your
senior leadership,
they're going to make some mistakes and
you've got to protect him and encourage
him to continue on to
try to be innovative.
If we wished to think clearly,
if you wish to free your mind,
if you wish to think clearly,
we must cease imitating.
If we wish to cease imitating, we
must make use of our imagination. Now,
how often is it that you see a
marine in his dress service dress,
blue uniform looking like
a statue of perfection?
How often is it you think that their
manual tells them that they have to make
use of their imagination? Yeah.
People don't get that image,
and I've said this before
and I'll say it again,
combat is an absolute
exercise and creativity.
That's what it is.
And you've got to use your imagination.
We must train ourselves for the unexpected
in place of training others for the,
for the cut and dried
audacity and not caution must be
our watchword got take some risks.
Got To take some risks.
Now here's a term
that I just like. As a matter of
fact, I'm going to use the l word.
I love this term.
The term is fighting power.
Fighting power is an organization's
ability to conduct combat operations by
overcoming challenges to lead,
compete and prevail on the battlefield.
Fighting power rests on mental,
intellectual and organizational
foundations in its manifestations in one
combination or another.
Our discipline and cohesion,
morale and initiative,
courage and toughness,
the willingness to fight and the
readiness if necessary to die.
Fighting power in brief is defined as
the sum total of mental and physical
qualities that make armies fight.
And you know what?
I just added something in there because
it actually says mental qualities that
make armies fight.
And I'm adding mental and physical
qualities cause we've talked about the
physical qualities and
how important it is.
Fighting power in brief is defined as
the sum total of mental and physical
qualities that make army fight,
make armies fight in.
What I like about this
idea of fighting power
is what can you do to improve
your fighting power today?
What can you do?
Is what you're doing helpful?
Are you moving it forward?
Are you increasing your fighting
power or are you decreasing it?
Are you going backwards?
That's the real question here.
Hmm.
And I think that when you realize that
what you do in your life is either doing
one or two things,
it's either increasing your fighting
power or it's your fighting power.
Cause if you're staying stagnant,
you're, you're basically going backwards.
And here's a little wrap up.
Here's the, uh, leadership principles.
Be Technically and tactically proficient.
Know yourself and seek self improvement.
Boom.
No your marines and look
out for their welfare.
Yeah.
Keep your marines informed.
Set the example.
Ensure the task is understood,
supervised and accomplished.
Train your Marines as a team.
Okay.
Make sound and timely decisions.
Develop a sense of responsibility
among your subordinates.
Little decentralized command.
Employ your unit in accordance
with its capabilities.
Seek responsibility and take
responsibility for your actions.
Once again,
ownership.
And I like the seek responsibility and
a little little seal sale saying that we
used to have was a look for work.
So if there's nothing going on,
look for work man.
You know,
say you see a new guy standing
there not knowing what to do. Hey,
go look for work means go pickup
security position, go help move bodies,
go do something, make something
happen, seek responsibility.
And this last statement
is just a note to remind everybody
of the troopers on the front lines.
Throughout history,
the time always comes in battle
when the decisions of statesman,
end of generals can no
longer affect the issue.
And when it's not the power of our
national wealth to change the balance
decisively,
victory is never achieved
prior to that point.
It can only be one after the battle has
been delivered into the hands of men who
move in.
Imminent danger of death.
And that's SLA Marshall.
Okay,
the folks on the front lines.
So for everyone out there that's
listening to this podcast,
that's all on the front lines right now.
I salute you all.
Let's get to the questions.
All right.
Okay.
First question from narco 31 11
okay.
Will you guys cover injury
recovery and the mentality,
the quick recovery and
advice, how to find physical
limit without injury?
Okay,
so for this one,
well first of all,
train hard but always trained smart,
you know,
don't do things that are going to
hurt you and this is a balance.
Just like everything else,
you have to push yourself hard
enough that you get stronger,
but at the same time you can't push
yourself so hard that you get injured.
So I think that's one of the keys.
I'll another key is making
sure you take adequate rest,
which of course I'm usually
guilty of not doing.
That being said, when you see
me training every day, I'm not,
you know,
I'm not going 110% every day.
There's some days where I roll into the
gym and I say, yeah, okay, this is not,
this is not a day to push myself on
the injury. Prone today, you know,
and so I will tape or my workout and
I'll usually do some other kind of
intensity.
But let's say I'm not going to lift
heavy weights or I'm not going to sprint
because I'm feeling tight and I don't
want to pull muscles. So you just,
you got to listen to
what your body is saying.
Another thing that I think is
important about it is, you know,
we talked about on the last podcast is,
you know,
changing your goals and constantly
chasing after different goals. You know,
we were going for a dead lift and then
you're going for a mile time run and then
you're going for number
of pull ups into your,
you're constantly kind of changing those.
And I think that is a good way to avoid
injury because you're not just hammering
the same thing over and over and over
again, which I think leads to injury.
Now that being said,
you don't ever want to just completely
stop, you know, elements of your workout,
you know,
you want to keep.
That's why it's good to not go
into these extreme directions.
And I'll tell you one what I think is
the most important thing for me for being
relatively injury free and be able to
list all my injuries on the next question,
but relatively injury free
is that I always work out,
I always work out and I think that
when people, I think when people
take extended periods of time off,
and by that I think, I mean, you know,
you're starting to get into
like two weeks, three weeks,
maybe a month of not doing anything.
I think when people come back from those
is when they get injured is when they
get hurt because their body's just,
it's still strong.
It's still thinks it can do what it
did three weeks ago, but it can't,
it's not conditioned for it. And that's
when that's when you get hurt. Uh,
another good piece I think
for recovery and is a,
is a MobilityWOD the Kelly k star,
you know,
go to mobilitywod.com and just look
at that, look at what he's doing,
look at what he's putting out and he's
got some great stuff to heal yourself and,
and square away your injuries.
I think stretching,
I think stretching is important,
but I think people take it to an access.
And I think when you do too much of it,
I think it's,
I think it's causes problems.
Um, I know, I know some,
some guys that have done extreme
yoga and I think extreme yoga is,
you know,
once you're,
once you go beyond what is
normal or a little beyond normal,
you start to injure yourself and I think
that's not good. And they get leads to,
you know, joint laxity where your, your,
your joints can actually move too much
and there's not enough holding them in
place and there the ability. Right. Right.
And so I think just listen to your body
and I think that the next part of this
question we'll answer
in the next question.
Just kind of add to that nutrition as
well. Eating enough. So a lot of people,
especially if they're trying to cut up
or, or, or drop some weight and you know,
if you're training for something, you
got to make weight that's, you know,
that's going to be a little
bit more specific strategy.
But a lot of times if we
will starve themselves,
I'm always telling people
like when they're feeling
negative or they're feeling
like their injury prone,
I'm always telling people
they're probably lacking fats.
They're probably lacking good fats,
you know? So I agree with you.
Diet is extremely important. Yeah. And
what, like when you, when you work on,
this is what I learned early on and an
understanding the importance of this I
think really, really helped is if
you eat right after you work out,
don't,
don't think that you're gonna eat a meal
and that's going to fuel your workout.
Cause he's like,
it takes a while for the calories to
go into your system to fuel a workout.
It's not going to do it in like an hour.
So I don't eat.
So go workout and then eat after so that
those calories in those nutrients will
help your body recover.
And within that hour,
that's when your body wants to
recover. Once those nutrients. Yes.
So doing that,
if you starve yourself or don't
eat or eat very little, you're,
your muscles are going to be recovered.
Your tendons are going to be a little
bit more weak, even when you do recovery,
didn't take in those nutrients. So you
will be way more prone. I probably,
I probably need to do a better
job of that as you. Well, I,
people always ask me and I, I get
done working out, you know what,
like five or six as well,
maybe six o'clock in the morning.
I'm done working out and I usually don't,
I usually don't eat until nine or 10,
you know,
so I probably need to
do a better job of that.
I'll often take echo Charles his
advice on that one. Yeah. That's um,
it's the funniest, but I haven't opened
mine, so it's cool. I can do that. Yeah.
Good. In the budding bill bodybuilding
world, that's like a no brainer.
It's called the anabolic
window and it's like,
you can see little jokes on it where
it's like of jumped through all this
anabolic window and it shows a picture of
like a guy, a d guy dying or something,
you know, it's like, it's a real
important thing and it helps so much.
We'll give it a shot.
Right on. Next question
from
what honey bees do.
Oh,
when it's all one word, it's
just kind of, it's strange. Okay.
What honey bees do not on the decoding.
Could be like walk though me.
These dough,
you don't care.
Be That honeybees.
Do you never know what the honey bees do?
What injuries?
What honeybees do not the hood.
All right, there you go.
You get a third chance.
What injuries have you
gotten and how did you adapt?
Uh, so obviously active
lifestyle, you know,
growing up and spending
my life in the seal teams,
ton of injuries from everything
I've had. Mcl, terror,
sprained ankles, shoulders,
wrists, slower back, elbows.
But the most serious actual
injury that I had, um,
was I had neck, I had neck surgery,
so I had a foraminotomy and my neck,
which is they go in and they scrape some
bone away from the frame and which hurt
bad and when they did it. And,
but it's been really good.
Um,
Aye
was real. I mean, I, I had like lost
movement in my arm for a little while.
My right arm from your neck, from
my neck, injury from the nerves,
just grinding over time and,
and you know,
I remember there's one part of seal
training where you're carrying these boats
on your head,
which is not that big of a deal,
but then the instructors
would jump from boat to boat.
So you get these 200 pound instructors
and they're just jumping at their boats
on your head and they're jumping
from boat to boat. And it's,
I remember an instructor jumping into
the boat landing pretty much where I was
and I remember hearing a
grinding noise in my neck and I,
you know, of course I was 19 years
old, so I didn't care, bring it on.
But they don't,
they don't do that anymore.
They actually don't jump from boat to
boat anymore, which is, which is cool.
They shouldn't because it's not
good for you. So, but, but anyways,
with all these injuries, whether it's
MCL tear or whether it's, you know,
high ankle sprains and,
and all kinds of ligament damages in my,
in my ankles and my lower back,
which I've mentioned a few times,
almost all muscular there.
Uh,
what I do is I do the same thing
with all of them. And that is,
I do whatever I can, you know, if I, if I,
when I hurt my knee and I couldn't squat,
I could do like a quarter squat.
I did a quarter squats,
you know,
I'd go out the garage and I'd
stand there with nobody waiting,
just do quarter squats and get
the blood moving. And you know,
I try and do my other body parts and
you know, could do pull up still.
And so I did dead hang.
Paul was,
cause I couldn't even move my
need at like Kipp and all right,
so I did what I could there, you know, so
you can't do ring dips, do regular dips.
If you can't do dibs, do pushups. You
can do push ups, push off of a wall,
whatever it takes to get something done.
You can't live that 40
kilogram Kettlebell lift,
the 24 kilogram Kettlebell,
just do something, move,
get the blood in there and not only
does to get the blood in there,
cause I always think that
the more you're moving in,
the more you're using that range of
motion, the faster you're going to heal.
You know, you're just circulating
more, repairing nutrients to your body.
So it would make sense to me that
that's going to help you heal.
Now of course you can read damage, you
can go worse, you know, if it hurts,
do a a quarter squat and so you do half
squat, you're going backwards, you know,
so you want to stay within the range of
motion where you're not reentering it or
making it worse.
So don't be stupid,
but do get the movement going.
And also,
I don't know what I would do mentally
if I like couldn't do anything at all.
Now when I hurt my neck
though, I was, I was laid up.
I didn't think I was going to be,
I was going to go to power through it.
And then the tough guy. Yeah, no,
I was laid up with my
head and just hurting and,
but I'll tell you as soon as I could
get up and start trying to walk around,
I did it. And like I said,
try to try to stay sane.
And then the other thing that happens is
when you have these injuries, you know,
you're, you got to adapt
your goals, you know,
and you gotta just got to set new
goals. Okay. You know, and, and really,
I've never really fully
regained the strength in my
right arm and my right pack.
It's not as strong as it was. And it's
definitely way weaker than my other side.
You know,
it's probably at 70 or 80% and you know,
I just have to say, okay, well
what can I do? It's like, okay,
you're going to be normal. You're a normal
human now. You know, so, so here's what,
here's, here's, here's what your
new goals are. And I'm s you know,
I'm still trying to improve and
get better at whatever it is,
but you know,
injuries are going to happen in life and
you gotta just do your best you can to
work through them as smartly
as you possibly can. And
kind of to add to the, the,
the train smart,
this may seem obvious,
but when you do like higher rep, like
heavier weight or not higher reps, sorry,
heavier weight,
lower reps or real explosive stuff,
you're going to be more prone to injury.
So even being just more conscious
of your movement. Yeah. And,
and really avoiding those types of
movements when you feel an injury start to
come out. Like if you get a
little lower back thing or,
or a shoulder thing for sure.
Um,
just be conscious of your movement way
more today I was deadlifting and I,
I was like, hmm, nope. Okay.
We're done deadlifting for
the day and, and you know, I,
I definitely spared myself being laid up,
you know,
and I just got out the roller and
just grounded out for a while, got off
the ball, grounded out for awhile.
But for sure you gotta listen,
you gotta pay attention and if you feel
that little twins, it's no big deal.
You know,
there's plenty of other ways to get your
get your workout on besides Jack and
the big steel. So yeah, you
um, like are your thing,
your body weight squats, you'll just
do it, you know, like if you're,
if you had a six squat workout planned
and you feel your lower back or it,
Ben is a big one where when you, when
you get after it and squats that'll um,
a lot of times act up.
Well I sprained my ankle sick enough
probably four or five months ago and it,
I couldn't do, it was weird.
It's one of those weird things.
I couldn't do overhead squats
but I could do overhead squats,
snatch,
yes.
I couldn't do overhead squats cause
it hurt my ankle for whatever reason.
But I could do front squats and regular
squats and I couldn't go to full debt.
The ones I could still go
to full depth on. Again,
I don't know why I'm not a physician.
Front squats felt the best.
So I started doing more and more front
squats at the time and then eventually,
you know,
and now I'm back to doing everything.
So figuring out what
you can get away with,
figuring out what you can do and new it
also went in regards to being conscious
of like your movement.
A lot of times I know this is,
this is the case for me were all get
little injuries from just like racking or
unpacking weight just because it's like,
well you're not need to do more
functional training, my friend.
I don't always get injured.
Little things, you know,
because that a lot of times
that is like it's unconscious.
I'm just putting this over here,
you know, and you're not. Meanwhile,
if you do a clean and jerk
and you're like, okay,
I'm going to focus on this good technique.
So again,
that goes along with being careful of
your mo movement being, being conscious,
conscious. Especially when you
feel when you hit that fatigue,
when you know you've been working
out for three weeks straight, hard,
very little risks, you're on it, you know,
and you start to feel these
little things come about.
I think it's important too,
to be conscious of those things.
And also to what you were saying earlier,
if my head's not in the game,
I'm not Jack and the big weights
cause you gotta be thinking about it.
You gotta be thinking about your body
position, you know, before you do, before,
before you just try and grab on this
big weight and throw it around. Yeah.
You gotta get your head in the game.
All right, next question. Uh,
this was actually my question.
A question from echo bind with a question
from someone else. Yeah. Yes, yes,
that's true. Okay. So public
speaking, right? How did you, like,
I've seen some of your speeches. How did
you get good at it? Because that's a,
that's a daunting nerve wracking
thing in fight. Like some people,
they prefer death over public speaking.
Literally.
That's heavy. So what's your, um,
what's your mindset, you know,
for keep you from it,
from being nervous.
And then that coupled with
another question here,
which we got from conquering
fear in general, right? Right. If
you're a failure or a fear of rejection,
fear of the unknown,
what would your advice be to someone
who wants to like start a business or a
major project? But they're, but
they're held back by fear. So
this is,
again,
it's interesting for me because public
speaking is not something that induces
fear and made, it never has. Uh,
but I know that it does
make people scared.
And I think that overcoming the key to
any overcoming any fear in my mind is,
we talked about this a little earlier,
wishes inoculation and this idea,
and I actually looked up the definition
of inoculation and it's the introduce
the introduction of a pathogen or antigen
into a living organism to stimulate
the production of antibiotics antibodies.
So you're giving yourself a little bit,
right? Right. You give yourself a little
bit and you build up off there and,
and that's what you do.
You take the small doses.
So it prepares you for the bigger, bigger
doses. And I, uh, one of my daughters,
my middle daughter,
she was really wanting to
be in the school play right.
And other plays around town
and Oh, you know, okay, cool.
Well that's cool. But she was horrified
to go out in front of an audience.
Horrified. And so I looked
up and I said, okay,
well how do you stop your kids from being,
getting stage fright is the one they call
it. And you know, I read about people,
what they did and what I did
was I said, I'd say, we're okay.
Uh, the singer Song for me, and it's not
that big of a deal cause I'm her dad.
And so she'd sing a song for me and even
then she'd be a little bit embarrassed,
but she'd sing a song for
me and then then, you know,
a couple of days they don't have my
wife, Hey, sing that song for both of us.
And then it was, oh my wife's
got a friend over, hey,
sing that song for the three of us.
Because how you get a mystery person,
an unknown in the room.
Okay.
So she's overcoming that fear and each
time she's getting a little bit more and
more confident because we took her to a,
what do they call tryouts, what's
tryout called audition. Audition.
We took her to a couple auditions where
it was her turn and she didn't go.
She broke down just crying and
just, just, just couldn't handle it.
And so then it was,
then it was a few of my wife's friends
were over then it was some of my friends
were over. So now you've got, you know,
guys and girls and each time she got more
and more confident and eventually she
just didn't care anymore and
she was totally confident
and she got the lead role
in the school play. She legitimately got
the lead role in the school play, so,
so she was able to overcome that fear.
And in the seal teams we
do the same kind of thing.
We know where you're going to get a knock
related against stress as much as they
can stress you out in the seal teams,
they're going to stress you out.
There's going to be machine gun fire,
you're going to be used to that.
They're going to be explosions going off.
You're going to be used to that.
We used to do, we used to do live
fire machine drills and, and, and uh,
I add drills, immediate action
drills. We are maneuvering around.
We do that without your ear protection.
And sometimes so you get
used to this crazy banging.
We don't do that anymore
because it's not smart. But uh,
but you do that to inoculate. It's like
what you were talking about earlier.
When that gun goes off, you should
be completely comfortable with it.
And there's a, uh, one of
my favorite stories on that,
one of my favorite stores,
but one of them, one of the, uh, a
buddy of mine who actually took my job,
I was a tasking your commander and he
actually took my job as task in your
commander.
And a flash bang is a grenade that you
throw into a room before you go into the
room and it makes a loud explosion and
smoke and then it allows you to enter in
on the room when the people that
are inside are now startled.
So you have an advantage.
Well occasionally, you know,
you have to open the door to throw the,
the crash in there and
occasionally someone will open
the door and someone will
run in by,
they didn't coordinate it well.
And so the open the door guy runs in
and then someone throws the crash.
And so now you're crashing yourself.
It's not that big of a
deal you got to use to it.
But what happened with one of his
new guys, you know, that happened.
So the door went open,
the guy went in and while the guys running
and somebody throws a crash in there,
the guy sees the crash and
he runs back out of the room,
which is not what you're supposed to do.
So this guy was the task unit commander
and he goes, Hey, come with me down here.
And so they walked down and he brought
them into a closet in the kill house and
just sat in there and
said, yeah, how's it going?
And they just sat there in the dark and
dropped like eight crashes at their feet
and just blasted the guy.
Cause you realize that you
just got to get inoculated.
You know, you just got to
overcome it. So that's kind of,
I guess my,
my theory here would be if you're
afraid of fighting and altercations,
go train Jiu Jitsu. If you're afraid
of heights, work on some rock climbing,
climbing. If you're afraid of the water,
it's the time to swim. It's time to surf.
It's trying to get out there.
If you're afraid of pull ups,
if you're a prey to pumps, do pull
ups. If you're in squats, do squats.
If you're afraid of public speaking,
go speak in public.
If you're afraid to start a business,
start a business, make it small.
And on all of these,
which you have to do is you have to
mitigate the risk and you have to ease
yourself into it.
But you got to go for it.
And eventually you will
overcome that fear.
But the hard part is you
got to take that first step.
You got to take that first step to begin
to inoculate yourself against the fear,
against the fear of the
thing that's in your mind.
Because that fear generally is
in your mind that, you know,
when you get up on stage,
do public speaking,
people are not going to throw tomatoes at
you and say, Oh my God, you're an idiot.
Get off the stage. No, they, they're
going to sit there, you know,
so there's nothing to fear it's
in, it's in your head. Hey,
those flash grenades don't
cause any damage to people.
They're just, I mean, you don't
like want them next to your eye.
They're rare and they're loud and they
make a big boom and during explosive.
Yeah. But yeah, they don't, they don't
hurt you. Right. Generally the days you,
they hadn't even days they stun you.
Yeah.
So like what if I had one in my pocket
and it went off? Yeah. You'd get a little,
you'd get a little something.
Not an Indian. I'd get hurt.
Not Injured. You'd get,
yeah. You get hurt, not injured.
Yeah, I can do lift or some trees.
You'd be sore. Yeah. Yeah. I never
let went off in my pocket. Yeah.
I always wonder about
does cause they're all right.
Next question. Um, okay.
And podcast number seven,
you answered the question,
which was essentially about how a
subordinate might cope with a leader who
wasn't competent. Um, so this,
this person is interested in your
thoughts on the opposite side of the coin.
For example, if you're that guy,
quote unquote, and you know it,
how can you still lead a team effectively
given the lack of competence, um,
given the lack of competence can undermine
the team's trust and confidence in
you.
So, so this question is,
you are that guy. Yeah.
You're the guy that
doesn't have the knowledge.
You're the guy that's an experience too.
You're the guy that just got hired.
That's good that he, you know
it. That's good, right? Yes.
He said he's done a good job by,
by recognizing that is step number one.
He's recognized that he's the
guy that he's inexperienced,
doesn't have the knowledge, et
cetera. So this, this question,
while it might seem like a tough question,
it's actually easier than
you might think because
competence and knowledge definitely
are very beneficial for leadership.
The knowledge piece and,
and knowing the technical side of
what you're trying to lead a team in.
But it is definitely not mandatory.
Now if you don't have it,
of course you should strive to get it
because it will make you a better leader.
But in certain situations there's times
where you have to lead and you have to
lead.
Now that does happen.
So what do you do and how do you lead
when you're in that situation and it's
actually pretty easy.
You lead almost the exact same you way
that you would in any other situation
humbly and with an open mind.
So leadership is the same
regardless of what you know.
Think about it. Leadership is the
same regardless of what you know.
What you're gonna do is you're going to
gather ideas cause you don't really have
in your own. So you're going to gather
them from the other people, right?
You're going to explore the
different methods, right?
Cause you don't know any
of the other methods.
So you're just going to explore
and say, oh, how would you do it?
Or how would you do it?
You're going to weigh the
different courses of action because
you're not sure which one
is going to be the best.
It's not going to be super evident,
which course of action is going to be the,
you're going to listen,
listen to what people are saying.
You're going to keep an open mind
and hear what they're saying.
Okay.
You're going to show that you're a quick
learner and you're going to listen in
and learn. And how do you show
that you're a quick learner.
You show that you're a quick
learner by being a quick learner.
And how do you be a quick learner
by studying? So when it comes,
when there's stuff that you should know,
then you study it and you learn it and
you prove and then you take all this
information that you've got and you
weigh the decision and then you make one.
And again, that's how you should
be leaving anyways. Right? So,
so let me ask you this just
because you know the most, right?
If you are the most
knowledgeable on the team,
does that mean you're gonna plan
everything yourself? No. No it doesn't.
Does that mean you're going to make
your decisions in a vacuum by yourself?
Just know if you're a good leader,
you're not going to do that at all.
Does it mean you're going
to make decisions and move
forward without consulting
with people? No, it doesn't.
So all this means is that you're
going to do all those things.
You are going to get
consensus from the group.
You're going to get people on board.
You're going to talk to them and see
what their, their ideas are. Any, again,
I shouldn't have used the word
consensus because you can always lead by
consensus. That can be, that can become
difficult, but you're going to listen.
You're going to learn,
you're going to talk to people about
what you're doing and that's how you're
going to lead. Again, it's
almost the exact same. The
only thing that gets added.
If you are sort of a technical expertise,
you can be a little bit more
of a sanity check on, you know,
let's say a plan that people
are coming up with. If, if,
if we were doing a computer, you
know, software engineering problem,
I would not be able to add my technical
expertise. But if, you know, for the comp,
the engineers came to me and
presented what their ideas were,
I'd be able to look at them
logically and say, okay,
explain to me how and ask enough
questions until I said, okay guys,
here's what I'm thinking here. I
think we should go with, you know,
method B or whatever and the other
people can kind of counter and then
eventually we can make
that decision happen.
So if I had the knowledge myself that
I could make that decision a little bit
easier and I could add a
little bit of a sanity check,
but it's not life and death.
Uh,
and the other thing that's interesting
is when you do have the knowledge
yourself,
you can,
you can actually come off as a know it
all, which is not a good leader. Yeah.
So in both cases,
whether you are the technical expert
or whether you're not the leadership
principles, stay the same, be
humble, be open minded, listen,
learn and lead.
Last question.
What is your greatest weakness and what
are you doing to work through or around
it?
What is my greatest weakness?
My biggest weakness?
And that's actually a hard question
because when I think about it,
frankly,
I am nothing bought weakness.
I'm not naturally strong.
I'm not naturally fast,
I'm not naturally flexible
and I'm certainly not the
smartest guy in the world.
And,
and I get emotional over stupid things
and I eat the wrong foods and I don't
sleep enough and I procrastinate and I
waste time and I cares too much about
stupid things and not enough
about important things.
And of course my ego is too big,
but at the same time, my mind is too
small and it's trapped inside itself.
But now that being said,
I have a saying and it's,
and you've probably
heard me say it before,
a person's strengths are often
their biggest weaknesses.
And so that also means that their
weaknesses can be their strengths.
So me,
I am weak in all those ways that I listed.
I am weak,
but I don't accept that I don't accept
that I am what I am and that that
is what I'm doomed to be.
No,
I don't accept that I'm fighting.
I'm always fighting.
I'm struggling and I'm scrapping and
kicking and clawing at those weaknesses to
change them to stop them.
Some days I win.
Okay.
Some days I don't,
but each and every day I get
back up and I move forward
with my fist clenched toward the battle,
toward the struggle
and I fight with everything I've got
to overcome those weaknesses and those
shortfalls and those flaws
as I strive to be just a
little bit better today
than I was yesterday.
Yeah,
and I think that that about
wraps it up for tonight and
like we always say,
if you want to continue this conversation
or you want to engage in one or you
want to hang with us virtually,
you can find us on Twitter.
I'm at Jockowillink and
echo is at echocharles.
Thanks for listening.
Thanks for subscribing,
thanks for leaving reviews.
Thanks for spreading the word.
Thanks for being better
and most of all,
thanks to all of you
for getting after it.
This is Jocko and echo,
and until next time
out.